it's cabbage time
so get ready for the cabbage
okay amazing rating
one one one one
that's slightly better than zero zero
zero
zero is my opponent here though
i feel like this is ideal opponent to
play the cabbage against
is the cabbage not meant to be
oh i'm so
sad opponent
i'm back
i just want to show my cabbage maybe
there's an egg opening and you just
haven't discovered yet kappa
yeah i feel like there's a lot of
openings that we haven't discovered yet
there's probably different types of egg
openings
like scrambled or fried
or french omelet
or humpty dumpty
okay uh
abort sorry
a macro
let's try this again
hey i'm playing dark rug haha
we played earlier
okay so the cabbage opening
it can start with c3 or c4
a cabbage it starts with c
and then we play a3
so c a
i think we know what's coming b
oh i have to play this move next
cabbage has two bees right
c a b b
yeah to play the cabbage opening you
have to understand how to spell cabbage
b
so far i've played the cab opening
c a b b
a
now i've played the kabba opening
g
hey it's a cabbage opening
this is such a bad opening but it's also
very nutritious
full of vitamins
unfortunately i'm not trapping the
bishop because there's bishop b4
look at this
c a
e b
oh it's so satisfying
okay i'll play oh let's not plunge her
up on
i was about to blunder my my c pawn
i'll play
i'll play d3 because why not
yeah cabbage accomplished
okay bishop e2
actually let's play f3
use my pawns
pawns are like tiny cabbages
i just realized i could play the cabbage
head opening
but the cabbage head would have required
h and then e and then a again which
maybe wouldn't have been possible
okay
okay now i'll just go for the cabbage
oh yeah i'm playing the cabbage ed
fh cabbage
wait cabbage dfh
yeah i've kind of lost my ability to
spell
yeah the pawns are slightly grinning
though which is kind of nice
i appreciate my opening choice
okay so i think from this point going
forward i'm in the play seriously i'm
going to try and
like work with what i've done to my
position
and still try and find
[Music]
ideas
oh my cabbages
or your cabbages
okay so now i'm actually kind of obeying
opening principles
of developing my
nights i brought my knight to h3 to
target g5
the knight and c3 can maybe come to e4
and
knights can start working together
it wants to hurt me a little bit
the knight's defended
crushing the bishop
maybe going for this at some
point also some future idea of forking
would require removing these things
thank you echo0101
i feel like the numbers there echo each
other
okay we might be trading bishops
which actually would be okay with me
because then it could be easier to play
c5 where in the world is eric rose and
diego
oh
are you implying i'm in san diego
or what if i changed my last name to
rosen diego
she don't know what to do here there's
rook b1
wg2 i'll play bishop g2
eventual idea of castling i might play
knight f2 first
and then go for castling
hey it's irene what's up irene
irene
[Music]
probably just waking up in riga
irene look at what opening i played
it's a cabbage opening c-a-b-b-a-g-e
it's so healthy
the irene is playing in the grand swiss
cabbage is probably not the type of
opening to play in like a serious
b-day rated tournament
okay the knight's attacks
knight has one safe square
oh i can show off my ab
a and then b
oh
d5 with a counter attack
okay so both knights are hanging
this pawn's not really pinned because my
queen defends her rook
i mean knight c5 looks nice
hitting the queen
now two things are eric will you be in
dubai this next month
yes
oh yeah if i guess uh mal and miller
just joined
i was talking earlier about how
yeah i'll be in dubai during the
world championship match
um i'll be one of the official
photographers
i was showing off the the camera earlier
too
i'll bring this to dubai
probably won't be bringing any cabbages
to dubai
there's probably some like agriculture
rules
with customs
what is this pawn structure quadruple
pawns
of white and black
let's just keep winning pawns
the queen is proving to be useful
so question about the zoom on this lens
it's a 270 to 200 millimeter lens
so you can get pretty close up
from standing far away
okay what to do here g4 maybe e4
just hit the bishop
i still have all eight pawns
my queen's a little bit attacked
like queen c7
it's weird that i just have a pawn
randomly controlling c7
okay black wants to hurt me again
so now it's time to castle
and if takes i take back with f pawn
opening that file
it's kind of sad though that's the first
pawn i've lost this whole game
but it's also kind of happy given
what's about to happen
take on g6
okay
oh this is no increment and rated
this is a rated game
oh i just realized
i just realized this queen can
move along the diagonal
it's not going to help though
okay
the cabbage opening
mission accomplished
i castle kind of laid in this game
again cassing it's a very typical middle
game principle
[Music]
at least for me
yeah i guess there's a lot of potential
openings
like there's uh
what else can we spell with uh the
letters a through h
cabbage baggage
oh egg
there is an egg opening
who was talking about discovering the
egg opening
the egg opening would be e3 or e4
and then g3 g4
do i just do a whole series of like food
openings
to play the dead opening
d4 e4 a4
d5
the dead head
to play the bad head opening
oh i feel like a a new youtube series is
coming
of just playing ridiculous openings
ah the dead beef opening
the egg face opening oh chad is so
creative
look at chat
ah
opening
yeah american airlines can't sue us if
we use
more than two a's
okay
if this goes on youtube let me know what
opening you want to see next
like the top upvoted youtube comment
suggesting an opening that i can spell
with a through h
i will play in a future video i feel
like we've discovered
a new realm of chess content
okay
oh the chad opening
oh that would be so chad
i should also mention it would have been
really bad if my opponent
played knight e4 here
because if i wanted to try for a true
cabbage i would have had to move my
g-pawn
and then get mated
i don't know what i would have done
you